Để một chiến đấu gơ et bà lắm biểu tưởng, cưng đây của phẩm hiện tại của anh,
năm bất đậm xuất gần một tháng tại SGA N Độ là điều hiếm thấy,
sự cộm ở đều từ từng muốn kh het cấp giôi thứ tiết.
Nhưng điều ki là, là không chỉ chiến mẹ way không thể xử trở tại coi.
Mà quá chính tiếp tận bảo giấn cũng mẹ chỉ hoán vì thiểu khi mình trên xụ.
Đều này làm sế lên câu hỏi về khá ngăng phản nước linh hoa của con đội anh chong các tỷ bạn bắt thường.
Zoo đã trên khai đổi kiến xử tự tổ sân bây hát merede,
và có sự phối hợp của chính quyền nảnh đầu. Chứ ngày 18, Vấn Chiu thế trở lại hoàn đầu,
rất lỗi từ lực trở sát đệ. Chúng khi đó, con ngày tăng hình và các linh kiện tựt mật,
một phía anh phải dưới sĩ giám sắp nghiêm nặp hai tư chiếc bày.
Giới truyết sát nhận định việc tháng sở mấy bây để đưa về nước bằng xe mấy bày,
là phương án khải thi nhất, nhưng cực kỳ phức tạp và dùi giấu cao về mặt bảo mật.
Món ngày chứ qua, ngày ngành của ấy, 18, bố là biểu thưởng công nghệ quân sự phân tay,
càng bị tổn 2, đồng thời phản anh sự thiếu trình bị cho các tình bản thân cấp từ phía anh.
Đây cũng là lời tệng báo với mọi cường quân sự trong thời đại.
Mà dùi giấu có thể đến từ chính thời tiết.